[Música]
los integrantes de la duma la cámara
baja del parlamento ruso ratificaron de
manera unánime un acuerdo para la
anexión de las repúblicas populares de
donierski y de las regiones de gerson y
saborilla hubo rechazo internacional por
haber realizado esta serie de referdos
que no contaron con garantías dentro del
derecho internacional y también
representó un capítulo más en la pérdida
territorial para Ucrania hubo también
como lo decía por rechazo a nivel
internacional Pero hay un gran reclamo a
organismos como la ONU la Unión Europea
la otan y actores importantes como
Estados Unidos por no haber hecho nada
para evitar la incorporación de estas
cuatro regiones a la federación de Rusia
que precisamente obliga a hacer cambios
internos dentro de la federación veamos
esta incorporación de estos cuatro
territorios ucranianos lleva a que Rusia
tenga que Modificar el artículo número
65 de la Constitución de la federación
por pasar de tener 85 sujetos federales
a tener 69 la población de Rusia también
aumenta pasa de 147 millones de
habitantes ahora superará los 150
millones de ciudadanos Al haber
incorporado estos territorios Rusia
entonces controla todas las costas del
mar de azofv prácticamente se convierte
en un mar interno y le permite también
proteger de una manera mucho más
acertada la Península de crimea que la
incorporó a la federación en el año 2014
si bien en las repúblicas populares de
doniebs y lugansk la mayoría de los
habitantes eran rusoparlantes a partir
de ahora el ruso va a ser el idioma
oficial El del uso diario El de los
medios de comunicación y de la
Administración pública y también el
rublo ruso pasa a ser la moneda de curso
legal será permitido el uso del idioma
ucraniano en conversaciones informales
entre los habitantes
Moscú ha puesto en marcha entonces este
plan de transición para llevar a una
plena incorporación de estos los
accesorios que tendrá lugar su proceso
final en enero del 2026 es decir les
falta todavía un proceso muy largo para
hacer completamente sujetos federales
dentro de la federación de Rusia según
un sondeo de opinión realizado por el
centro de estudios de la opinión Pública
que es un organismo afín al kremlin afín
al presidente Putin el 75% de los rusos
apoyan el ingreso a Rusia de estas
repúblicas populares de donitz y Lucas y
las regiones de saporiya y gerson como
territorios de la Federación
Entonces qué respuesta a nivel militar
puede dar Ucrania que afirma haber
recuperado la Ciudad de Lima en algunas
zonas cercanas también a la ciudad de
harkif es esto suficiente para
garantizar una especie de triunfo de la
batalla no de la guerra si bien las
tropas rusas se han replegado en algunos
puntos importantes la incorporación de
estas cuatro regiones representan un
triunfo por lo menos desde el punto de
vista de los rusos que también confirmó
que ha movilizado acerca de 200.000
hombres adicionales a la zona de batalla
está entonces Rusia verdaderamente en
aprietos o triunfando la comunidad
internacional va a seguir presionando al
kremlin Cuál será el paso a seguir por
parte de la otan de la Unión Europea
Ucrania y Rusia para analizar este tema
saludamos a Román Ortiz él es analista
de seguridad y defensa del centro de
seguridad Internacional de la
universidad Francisco de vitoria él se
encuentra en la ciudad de Washington en
Estados Unidos y desde Bogotá se conecta
a Jesús agreda él es internacionalista y
profesor del departamento de relaciones
internacionales de la facultad de
ciencias políticas de la pontificia
universidad javeriana que está ubicada
en la ciudad de Bogotá en Colombia
nuestros televidentes ustedes que nos
están sintonizando hasta ahora recuerde
que también son parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook en instagram no se encuentran
como arroba el debate guión bajo
f-24@santilogo que es mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta numeral el debate f24
recuerde también que todos los
contenidos están disponibles en
diferentes plataformas de podcast
estamos en Apple podcast en Spotify
deezer y tuning
vamos a comenzar le doy entonces la
palabra a Román en la ciudad de
Washington El Punto de partida en esta
ocasión y la pregunta que con la que
abre el debate es si estas
incorporaciones de estas cuatro regiones
a la federación de Rusia es claramente
un triunfo para Rusia o es un arma de
doble filo para este país o es una
medida desesperada tomada por las
autoridades rusas porque verdaderamente
se están sintiendo acorralados por las
fuerzas ucranianas
creo que lo primero que es importante en
este sentido es distinguir entre
realidad y ficción la realidad de lo que
está pasando en el campo de batalla y la
ficción que nos quiere hacer creer el
kremlin
formalmente hablando Rusia ha
incorporado a estas regiones se las han
lesionado
a través de unos referéndums que han no
es que hayan carecido de garantías es
que en realidad Así han sido una
completa falsa verdad pero en la
práctica a lo que está pasando Es que
Rusia está perdiendo el control del
territorio que precisamente acaba de
anunciar que sea anexionado entonces hay
una paradoja digamos hay una enorme
brecha entre la realidad y la ficción la
ficción legal que están creando de que
incorporan estas zonas al territorio
Ruso y la realidad de que las tropas
ukelelenas les están expulsando de ellos
Para qué sirve Entonces este movimiento
del kremlin para dos cosas La primera es
para enmascarar lo que en este momento
cada vez parece más claro que es una
derrota militar sin precedentes para las
fuerzas armadas rusas
después de perder
fracciones muy grandes del territorio
que controlaban en el norte de Ucrania
ahora las fuerzas rusas se están
sintiendo fuertemente presionadas en la
región de kerson están combatiendo en
una posición muy complicada porque
tienen están combatiendo de espaldas al
río y si Ucrania tiene éxito podría
convertirse en una gran catástrofe
militar para Rusia No Solamente porque
recuperaría una de las ucranias
recuperaría una de las ciudades más
importantes de un puerto clave en el mar
Negro para Ucrania sino Además porque
las tropas rusas que están combatiendo
en esa zona tienen muy pocas tienen
muchas dificultades para poder retirarse
para poder replegarse y yo solo las
convertiría empresa de la de la de la
ofensiva de Ucrania verdad el otro
objetivo es incrementar es incrementar
la credibilidad de La amenaza nuclear si
estos territorios se convierten en Rusia
entonces Argumenta Putin él tiene más
razones para pensar en utilizar el arma
nuclear
sí importante el punto que pone de
partida Romano Ortiz en la ciudad de
Washington vamos Entonces hasta Bogotá
allí nos escucha a Jesús agreda Jesús
Gracias por acompañarnos hoy en el
programa Cuál es su perspectiva su
opinión El Triunfo esto se puede ver
como un triunfo para Rusia es un arma de
doble filo esto le va a empezar a cobrar
factura pronto al gobierno ruso o es
simplemente una medida porque
verdaderamente están en aprietos
primero Buenas tardes Muchas gracias por
la invitación no estoy completamente
acuerdo con lo que ya se dijo
Efectivamente es una situación o es una
medida algo desesperada a través de la
cual digamos y haciendo uso de una
amenaza potencialmente nuclear se
intenta disuadir un éxito militar
ucraniano que es innegable que
efectivamente Rusia no puede negar que
es extremadamente visible que puten
mismo no ha podido contener porque los
argumentos que hemos escuchado es que
incluso Putin ha tomado el control de
ciertas de ciertas tropas y finalmente
control de ciertas digamos actividades
militares en terreno y ahí es donde al
parecer efectivamente hay un fracaso no
hay posibilidad de contener la contra
ofensiva con algunos ese esfuerzo no ha
sido efectivo y eso mismo es atado una
crítica interna hacia el gobierno Putin
que lo ha colocado una posición también
muy difícil dentro de la política
interna incluso contra sus propios
digamos simpatizantes nacionalistas en
algunos casos que ya ven con una
corriente muy crítica el desempeño del
presidente Y eso Por supuesto lo obliga
a tomar medidas algo desesperadas y me
parece que esa anexión es la
demostración de esa manera vamos a
hablar de esas críticas internas porque
vienen desde diferentes sectores de la
sociedad rusa Jesús continuó con usted
para hacer la ronda a la inversa después
de esta incorporación o supuesta
incorporación porque pues ya ustedes lo
explican como en la práctica no va a ser
tan sencillo como lo lo hace ver el
kremlin A qué se está exponiendo Rusia
por parte de sanciones de la comunidad
internacional A qué se está exponiendo
el gobierno del presidente Vladimir
Putin con esta con esta incorporación
qué le espera a Rusia
pues le esperan más sanciones el
problema es el que es que la efectividad
de esas sanciones sobre todo en el
ámbitos en ámbitos multilaterales son un
poco complejas ya vimos que por ejemplo
el esfuerzo de algunos de algunos
estados en el Consejo de Seguridad por
declarar ilegal los referendos Fueron
vetados por Rusia lo que significa que
la capacidad de acción es limitada
Entonces el siguiente paso es tratar de
de imponer sanciones o de alguna forma
condenar las acciones en un contexto más
amplio en el marco de la asamblea
general pero igual en ese mismo en ese
mismo ámbito vemos que
pues las decisiones no son tan
vinculantes por supuesto como el Consejo
de Seguridad lo podría imponer o lo
podría proponer Y eso hace que digamos
aunque aunque estas funciones están en
el papel en la práctica desde la ONU al
menos las sanciones difícilmente se van
a poder implementar lo que nos deja
entonces con sanciones mucho más
bilaterales de alguna forma mucho menos
multilaterales de parte de la Unión
Europea por supuesto si ya se ha
anunciado algunos mecanismos adicionales
mucho más dirigidos no sólo el país sino
nuevos sectores y sobre aquellas
personas que participaron directamente
en en este fiasco del referéndum en
digamos en esta broma si quieren
Pues de parte y por otro lado de parte
de Estados Unidos vemos un apoyo mucho
más significativo Ucrania que ya ha
tomado la decisión de no sentarse a
negociar con este gobierno sino buscar
una solución netamente militar entonces
lo que veremos es un apoyo internacional
a una Ucrania pero para digamos lograr
aún mayores ventajas militares
aprovechando el contexto en el cual se
encuentra Claro ya vemos ese paquete de
ayuda para Ucrania por parte de
Washington de 625 millones de dólares
anunciado recientemente romal su opinión
sobre este tema las consecuencias que
pueden llegarle a Rusia a raíz de esta
medida de la incorporación
bueno efectivamente yo creo que una de
las cosas que han demostrado este esta
guerra de hecho es que los organismos
multilaterales y en particular las
Naciones Unidas sirven de poco cuando
los agresores están dentro verdad Y en
este caso estamos hablando de Rusia y en
este sentido en este caso digamos Rusia
cuenta con el apoyo de China
dicho esto
Me parece que la clave acá se ha vuelto
a mover O se está moviendo ahora en el
campo de batalla a las anexiones no van
a dejar de ser más que un incentivo aún
más grande para que Ucrania acelere las
operaciones militares porque ahora todo
el territorio que no recupere tan rápido
como pueda sobre todo antes de que
llegue el invierno y las operaciones
militares bajen de ritmo corre el riesgo
de que Rusia diga de alguna manera
cristalice este Movimiento Político En
consecuencia las las operaciones
militares ucranianas se acelerar y yo
creo que también lo más importante que
está haciendo la comunidad internacional
y particularmente de los Estados Unidos
que es proporcionar equipo militar todo
el equipo militar posible a los
ucranianos para para que estos respondan
exitosamente a la agresión rusa verdad
Entonces no creo que le espere nada muy
bueno a Rusia de esto creo que en este
momento Putin se encuentra en una
posición muy difícil incluso recurrir
armas nucleares tácticas serían armas
nucleares de pequeño tamaño
representaría un representa una opción
tremenda primero porque condena le
condenaría digamos
acabaría su supervivencia política
estaría descartada por un lado y por
otro lado
no no no provocaría un cambio sustancial
en el campo de batalla verdad de forma
que la situación es muy difícil para
Rusia incluso después de este movimiento
Román continuó con usted para
preguntarle de amlo ambos lados de el
campo de batalla hablemos primero desde
el lado ucraniano usted ya mencionaba
que es el momento para que Ucrania
presione el acelerador para tratar de
recuperar la mayor cantidad de terreno
en el este del país qué más puede hacer
Ucrania para
seguir adelante con esta contraofensiva
y seguir arrinconando a Rusia como según
ellos mismos han dicho está sucediendo
Mire yo creo que estamos en una dinámica
en la cual la clave es quién está
movilizando recursos de manera más
rápida verdad los ucranianos han
demostrado una enorme capacidad para
movilizar a su población para encuadrar
a digamos nuevos soldados en unidades
operativas y meterlos en el campo de
batalla el cuello de botella ucraniano
es en el ritmo y la velocidad del
suministro de armas de occidente
entonces a lo más importante para
Ucrania ahora y para la causa ucraniana
es que reciba más armas más equipo
militar y más entrenamiento occidental
lo más rápidamente posible por el lado
ruso El problema es que el sistema
militar ruso está roto por dentro no
importa que Putin haya móvil haya haya
diga que ha movilizado 300.000 nuevos
ciudadanos para encuadrarlas en las
fuerzas armadas probablemente primero
son bastantes menos porque el sistema de
movilización está en unas condiciones
muy lamentables Pero además es que esas
reclutas hay que entrenarlos sin
cuadrarlos ponerlos mandos
encuadrarlos en unidades operativas
equiparlos y desplegarlos y todo el
sistema que hace posible eso la
logística las comunicaciones la
disponibilidad de suficientes oficiales
y suboficiales todo ese sistema en el
caso ruso está completamente roto
Entonces no hay mucho que Rusia puede
hacer en este momento
Ese es el realmente el problema la la
gran pregunta es si Ucrania va a poder
mantener el momento en el ritmo de las
operaciones Pero eso depende más de la
logística ucraniana que de la capacidad
rusa para resistirse que es cada vez más
baja incluso los soldados rusos han
dicho que tienen serios problemas para
garantizar el suministro en algunos
puntos donde están haciendo presencia su
opinión Jesús en la ciudad de Bogotá
sobre lo que puede hacer Ucrania y Rusia
para los siguientes días
sí no Román lo he dicho ya muy bien
efectivamente el problema de Rusia es
digamos ya la parte material pero fuera
de eso me gustaría mencionar también el
tema de motivación porque sí
efectivamente
mencionado que ya han sido reclutados
200.000 personas pero
analicemos cuántas personas han tratado
de escapar del país para evitarse
reclutados y veremos que la cifra
termina siendo en últimas podría
terminar siendo muy parecida lo cual
significa que la motivación es un factor
muy importante y que vale la pena tener
en cuenta si en el caso ucraniano vemos
un ejército equipado digamos obviamente
hay limitaciones pero pues hay
motivación sobre todo y llegamos ahí hay
un esfuerzo muy significativo de una
coordinación muy efectivo por liberar un
territorio que se considera o que se ve
como claramente ocupado de un agresor
externo en el caso del ejército ruso Hay
un problema motivacional de fondo muy
grande porque justamente el mismo
gobierno no ha sido capaz de justificar
a esa población o digamos a su propia
población la necesidad durante esta
guerra y la necesidad de estas
operaciones militares es decir vimos con
la movilización parcial de una serie de
movilizaciones y una serie de protestas
en contra de la decisión que demuestra
que efectivamente no hay una
comunicación muy clara entre lo que el
gobierno está haciendo y lo que la
población está está está observando
así que sin duda Ucrania tiene una
enorme ventaja en este momento pero
digamos que solo puede aprovechar con
solo puedes seguir aprovechando si hay
un apoyo externo que es el que el
presidente ha estado tratando de
conseguir pero que obviamente va digamos
está tomando tiempo en llegar Jesús aquí
volvemos otra vez a un punto que hemos
analizado a lo largo de estos peces
desde que empezó la
invasión al territorio ucraniano y es
este exceso de propaganda por parte de
los dos lados vemos a Rusia hablando de
esta incorporación hablando de estas
cifras que yo daba al inicio en la
introducción del 75% de los rusos a
favor de esta incorporación de estos
territorios pero vemos que la realidad
en terreno pues es muy diferente
otra vez un exceso de propaganda
triunfalista por parte del kremlin y
también qué balance se puede hacer de la
propaganda del lado ucraniano porque
también Ucrania ha sabido manejar muy
bien los medios de comunicación para
despertar esa empatía a nivel
internacional como el país que está
haciendo invadido
sí comenzando con la parte de Rusia
efectivamente
vemos que hay una enorme propaganda pero
el problema es que hay una ruptura de
alguna forma entre la propaganda y la
realidad que se percibe es decir si el
gobierno viene diciendo que está una
operación militar especial hace unos
años y que están ganando y que
Finalmente solo han tenido algunos
reveses menores pues la gente entiende
que no hay ninguna razón para movilizar
300.000 personas es decir Es evidente
que que hay un fracaso en el discurso
versus la realidad y eso hace que las
personas mismas empiecen a cuestionar
mucho digamos la situación real de la
guerra y eso explica porque las personas
están tratando de irse del país o porque
están tratando de protestar en el caso
ucraniano digamos Esa esa incoherencia o
bueno esas esas esas situaciones de
incoherencia no han sido tan evidentes y
el discurso ha sido mucho más coherente
y constante y mucho más de alguna forma
comprobable en terreno en la mayoría de
las situaciones Y eso la una enorme
ventaja ahora fuera de eso Por supuesto
tal como ya lo mencionó muy bien
una situación de digamos arrancan de una
situación de inferioridad porque son la
víctima de una agresión externa y Por
ende de entrada su discurso tiene mucha
más credibilidad y donde además tienen
representantes y líderes están tan
carismáticos como el mismo presidente de
alguna forma un peso adicional a ese
discurso final claro Román continuó con
usted en la ciudad de Washington ya
hemos hablado aquí algunos puntos sobre
esas grietas esas críticas que han
comenzado a caer en el kremlin al
interior de la federación o puntos
claves por ejemplo este fin de semana el
diario ruso son los que haya parada
presentaba un panorama general del
conflicto bastante negativo cosa que no
es habitual en los medios rusos hablaba
justamente de lo que yo decía los
problemas de abastecimiento la escasez
de personal mala coordinación entre las
tropas los errores tácticos que han
cometido en terreno un medio que es afín
al gobierno está publicando eso y
también veíamos otro punto importante
ese comentario hecho por el líder
checheno ramsam cadiroft que criticó
muchos de estas operaciones tácticas de
los militares rusos y dijo Es el momento
de utilizar armas nucleares porque es lo
que nos queda hacer
Bueno yo yo creo que
está claro que están apareciendo está
apareciendo descontento
en Rusia Yo creo que es que es bastante
evidente Me parece que hay que entender
bien la política rusa en el sentido de
que las discrepancias dentro de dentro
de la población pueden ser más o menos
importantes pero la sociedad civil por
sí misma no es suficientemente fuerte en
este momento como para poder desafiar
directamente el control de Putin Me
parece que la clave Acá está en qué
puede estar pasando dentro de la élite
gobernante rusa de lo que de lo que
normalmente hace llamado la oligarquía
verdad rusa ese núcleo en torno a esa
clase política y económica en torno a
Putin y a mí me gustaría señalar un par
de cuestiones primero Putin tiene una
apuesta muy personal por el control de
Ucrania una apuesta que no
voluntariamente Comparte el resto de la
élite política rusa la élite política
rusa no quiere perder Pero estaría
dispuesto a hacer digamos a concesiones
de una manera más sencilla que para
Putin que es una apuesta personal el
segundo punto que me parece clave acá es
cómo está digamos a manejando y cómo
cómo está manejando esta crisis Putin lo
que está haciendo es confiar en líderes
regionales dentro de Rusia verdad En ese
sentido es muy muy significativo cómo
está manejando la movilización del
reclutamiento de nuevos soldados lo está
haciendo a través de los líderes
regionales rusos verdad Y eso significa
que está entregando más y más poder
político a las regiones y cada y
perdiendo el control sobre ellas en el
con ese escenario en el corto plazo Yo
diría que tiene todavía las palancas
claves de poder para prevenir algo así
como un es decir todo estos rumores que
han estado pasando en estos meses sobre
la posibilidad de un golpe de palacio
que le sacase del poder Pero a medida
que vaya pasando el tiempo es muy
probable que la región los políticos
regionales comiencen a sentir cada vez
primero más autonomía y por otra parte
menos interés en continuar respaldando
un líder que les ha condicionado esta
crisis y en consecuencia es posible que
sea desde las regiones desde donde surja
una digamos un movimiento que puede
provocar el desplazamiento de Putin del
poder verdad Román en ese orden de ideas
y precisamente al verse con este
descontento por parte de las regiones de
las diferentes repúblicas y oblatos que
conforman el país viendo que
militarmente los resultados no están a
su favor en el frente de batalla vuelve
y queda sobre la mesa esa posibilidad
que Rusia juega cada tanto y son las
armas nucleares
han dicho que es momento de
pero las armas nucleares de pequeño
calado pequeña de pequeño tamaño
sigue siendo una opción muy arriesgada
pero dada la desesperación en la que se
pueden ver podría ser una carta jugada
hay un riesgo Sin lugar a dudas a Rusia
ha conservado varios miles
aproximadamente unas 2.000 armas
nucleares tácticas de pequeño tamaño
para que digamos los
la audiencia se haga una idea estaríamos
hablando de armas nucleares que podrían
ser algo más grande que las hiroshimas o
más o hasta la mitad de la bomba de
Hiroshima en términos de potencia verdad
desde desde 0.5 kilotones hasta
aproximadamente 12 o 15 kilotones de
potencia
hay varios problemas para esto verdad
digamos primero no está claro que si
Putin toma una decisión de este tipo la
línea de Mando rusa le vaya a hacer caso
porque sabe las consecuencias que
tendría una decisión así no ya para él
no para Rusia como país sino para cada
uno de ellos individualmente verdad el
segundo problema es que la efectividad
de el uso de Estas armas sobre el campo
de la pantalla es muy limitada verdad
estamos hablando de unidades que están
en movimiento que están dispersas y un
arma nuclear evidentemente es un
dispositivo de una enorme potencia pero
no sería capaz de revertir el escenario
el escenario estratégico por sí misma el
tercer punto es la respuesta de la otan
verdad y de los Estados Unidos y parece
claro aunque se ha mantenido una
ambigüedad muy explicable porque parte
del intento de disuadir a Rusia es no
decirle lo que podría pasar que la
respuesta de la otan incluiría
represalias de carácter convencional no
nuclear es decir las fuerzas armadas de
la otan atacarían a las rusas pero
haciendo uso de fuerzas convencionales
no nucleares y segundo probablemente la
entrada de tropas de la otan dentro de
Ucrania en apoyo de Ucrania y además de
eso y este es mi último punto me parece
que es clave también pensar que el uno
el socio más importante que tiene en
este momento ru el apoyo de alguna
manera avergonzante pero en cualquier
caso crítico que tiene en este momento
Rusia que es china
está en contra de una escalada de esa
naturaleza porque los efectos de eso
sobre la situación económica mundial
sería de una gravedad extrema Entonces
todos esos factores hacen que aunque
haya una posibilidad porque las armas
nucleares están ahí y la doctrina rusa
habla de su uso cuando hay una situación
militar crítica como en este momento hay
muchos factores que pueden disuadir a
Rusia de dar ese paso verdad claro
de una escalada de una magnitud pues
difícil de comprender a lo que podría
llegar este conflicto Román pero es un
escenario posible parte del Análisis nos
lleva hasta allá Jesús veámoslo Entonces
ahora desde el otro lado del escenario
posible y es esa mesa de diálogo en este
momento completamente cerrada el
presidente de Ucrania polo de mercele
dijo que es imposible conversar con
Rusia en este momento a raíz de los
hechos que han tenido lugar en los
últimos días Es decir la incorporación o
la o el intento incorporación de estas
cuatro regiones a la federación el
diálogo Qué pasa No puede haber una
conversación que Moscú Turquía otra vez
de pronto podría entrar a mediar
no en este momento tal como lo menciono
muy bien efectivamente la puerta del
diálogo se ha cerrado Se ha cerrado de
manera bastante fuerte y de entrada la
verdad es que la negociación era muy
difícil porque básicamente la única
digamos la condición que Ucrania ponía
sobre la mesa para entrar a negociar
pero le retirada de las tropas de Rusia
sobre los territorios ocupados
eventualmente la solicitud se amplió a
crimea y de ahí básicamente la
posibilidad de negociación se eliminó
porque tal como ya lo vimos en terreno
putín de alguna forma su posición
política es que no puede perder Y
obviamente liberar o retirarse de los
territorios ocupados sería una forma de
perder Así que no es solo que Ucrania de
alguna forma no está interesada en
negociar es que también Rusia no está
dispuesta a negociar lo mínimo que sería
la integridad territorial sobre la base
mínima de la aceptación del
reconocimiento de la integridad
territorial ucraniana eso significa que
efectivamente no hay negociación y creo
que en este momento no hay tampoco
digamos una intermediario que pueda
jugar ese papel efectivamente se han
mencionado la posibilidad de Turquía
pero vimos por ejemplo como dos días
antes de la decisión de anexarse las
regiones bueno de promover la idea de
los referendos el presidente había dicho
que Rusia estaría dispuesta a buscar una
posible solución dialogada lo que por
supuesto dejó muy mal parado al
presidente de Turquía demostrando que
tal vez digamos una cosa es lo que es lo
que él está percibiendo el conflicto o
incluso peor escenario una cosa es lo
que le está diciendo el gobierno de
Moscú y otra cosa es lo que está
haciendo el terreno lo que demuestra de
nuevo que la posibilidad de una
negociación y la posibilidad digamos de
una intermediación turca es muy muy
limitada y entonces eso sumado con 111
unos intereses completamente divergentes
sobre lo que podría hacer una
negociación y sobre todo los resultados
que debería tener esa negociación
implica que efectivamente no es una
posibilidad viable en este momento y sin
haber diálogo Jesús entonces vuelve en
estas insistencias Por parte por ejemplo
de Ucrania de ejercer más presión sobre
Rusia y ahí es vuelven estos llamados
para que sea declarada Rusia como un
estado terrorista o un estado que apoya
el terrorismo esto a nivel internacional
en que repercutiría para este país en
términos legales o o económico o
político
Bueno ahí hay evidentemente digamos hay
unas sanciones adicionales fuera de las
que puede haber y ahí sobre todo una
prisión moral adicional desde el punto
de vista digamos de exclusión del
sistema internacional es decir la idea
sería
determinar de destruir la imagen de
Rusia que Rusia pues está destruyendo
por sí sola pero sería sería destruir la
imagen de Los Internacionales y
asociándolos ya con un con algo mucho
más digamos problemático para para este
mismo sistema que es el formato del
terrorismo
Román Quiero conocer su opinión sobre
esta posibilidad de una mesa de diálogo
como lo decía Jesús en este momento
bloqueada cerrada Pero entonces Cuáles
pueden ser las opciones para buscar una
solución a este conflicto
bueno el problema es que
las posibilidades de diálogos son nulas
por varias razones una de las más
importantes es que
cuando Ucrania digamos lo que se definen
Incluso como las fronteras digamos la
salida de las tropas rusas
tienen ahora mismo dos perspectivas
distintas desde Ucrania y incluso desde
sectores digamos rusos que no están
cercanos a Putin Es decir para muchos
rusos crimea es parte de de Ucrania
Perdón es parte de Rusia por mucho que
por mucho que legalmente hablando si
crimea sea evidentemente territorio
ucraniano pero el hecho de que crimea
fuese unido a la entonces República
soviética de Ucrania en los años 50 y
que hasta ese momento fuera parte de
Rusia hace que haya haya debate sobre Si
eso debe ser de considerar como parte de
Ucrania y todo esto hace mucho más
difícil de alguna manera llegar a algún
punto de acuerdo en el sentido de qué
significaría La retirada rusa Incluso si
en algún momento
Putin o un líder ruso alternativo
estuviese dispuesto a garantizar esa
retirada Entonces ese lado está
bloqueado yo creo que la otra salida
digamos la de una de una de una victoria
militar es la que parece que se está
abriendo pero hay que también pensar que
la enorme cantidad de territorio que en
este momento todavía controla Rusia y en
consecuencia yo creo que hacia donde
está yendo el conflicto es hacia una
rinconamiento de Rusia pero pero todavía
digamos manteniendo Rusia una ocupación
de una parte relevante de Ucrania
digamos de alguna manera de lo que
estaríamos hablando de una desde alguna
clase de partición que no significaría
la paz Pero significaría al menos una
bajada en la intensidad de las sobre
todo a partir de que llegue el invierno
Más allá de eso una solución del
conflicto a digamos definitiva es algo
que no se alcanza de ver principalmente
porque esa no ha sido la política de
Putin Nunca es decir Putin mantiene
sistemáticamente abiertas conflictos de
Rusia con otros países en la periferia
Rusia rusa le recuerdo el caso de Acacia
y osetia con Georgia el caso de
transnistía con con moldavia y ahora el
caso de Ucrania es decir
Putin Abre conflictos pero no es capaz
de encontrarles una salida me Temo que
esta vez a pesar de que las operaciones
militares Están yendo radicalmente en su
contra vamos a encontrarnos con una
situación parecida a los ucranianos van
a recuperar mucho más territorio pero a
pero Rusia todavía va a mantener abierta
la guerra verdad Porque además mientras
Mante tierra abierta Putin puede
reclamar que no ha perdido por mucho que
esté perdiendo Bueno pues llegamos a la
parte final del programa Román y Jesús
hagamos las conclusiones de lo que deja
este capítulo de este conflicto entre
Rusia y Ucrania con esta nación de estos
cuatro territorios estas victorias como
lo reclaman ambas partes dependiendo del
punto de vista que se mire Cuál es la
reflexión que ustedes hacen la gran
conclusión de lo que deja este episodio
porque bueno en esta semana Puede
ocurrir cualquier cosa en este conflicto
todo está sobre la mesa Puede ocurrir
cualquier episodio nuevo en este
conflicto Jesús adelante
bueno personalmente creo que estamos
yendo una situación extremadamente
delicada sobre todo en la cual Rusia
debido al fracaso de alguna forma del
campo militar se estaba arrinconando el
gobierno ruso se está rinconando en una
situación extremadamente sensible es
decir donde donde se
retrae de alguna forma se pone ante una
posición en el cual La amenaza nuclear
Parece ser la única alternativa que le
queda por evitar perder lo que se ha
ganado Y eso Por supuesto puede poner al
presidente una situación muy delicada o
por un lado de alguna forma se echa para
atrás y acepta La derrota y digamos
pierde por supuesto influencia y
popularidad política entre los grupos
políticos que todavía lo apoyan o por el
contrario tomó la decisión de empezar a
utilizar armas tácticas Y eso en
cualquier los dos escenarios
extremadamente destructivo para el
futuro de la región y finalmente el
futuro del mundo
Román para el cierre del programa su
conclusión
bueno dos cuestiones que me parecen
fundamentales primero no estamos
hablando en este caso de un conflicto en
el que tengamos que mirar los dos lados
para encontrar un punto de equilibrio
digamos tenemos un lado que ha invadido
agredido y miente sistemáticamente Y
tenemos otro lado que se está
defendiendo y que a pesar de que haya
demostrado una habilidad muy grande y
estoy hablando del lado que se está
defendiendo evidentemente su cránea y
estoy hablando de que y y digamos Más
allá de que de que de que tenga un
manejo habilidoso de la comunicación
estratégica Ucrania no miente
sistemáticamente como lo hace Rusia
Entonces por un lado no hay espacio para
la neutralidad aquí Rusia es el culpable
de la guerra Ucrania está defendiéndose
por otro lado digamos de cara al futuro
lo que vamos a tener es un conflicto más
largo incluso Aunque Rusia está
claramente perdiendo mientras Putin está
en el poder el conflicto se va a
prolongar en consecuencia tenemos que
prepararnos para una guerra larga y
probablemente para que lo que todo el
mundo quiere que es la vuelta de alguna
manera la normalidad tengamos que asumir
que la normal la normalidad como la
pensábamos ya no existe y no va a
existir nunca más pues a Rumanía Jesús
les agradezco por haber hecho este
análisis para la audiencia de Francia 24
es todo por hoy En nombre del equipo
técnico Les agradecemos la sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Pedro Ruiz y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera Pueden seguir con más
información en France 24 sigan con
nosotros
[Música]